hi i'm jill sobiel and i'm here on the  amazing john lennon educational tour bus  and we're here at ted active in palm  springs  and we've been working all week on this  song and video  called what the world needs now and i  hope you like it  what the world needs now  what the world needs now  what the world  now  what the world needs  education empathy  celebration more honeybees a lot more  things that are free simpler simplicity  architecture restoration  bicycles imagination  clean cars to go real far  jet packs flying to the start  oxytocin honest bliss  philanthropic technologies  is  ukuleles  what the world needs now what the world  needs now what the world needs now what  the world needs now what the world needs  now what the world is  oh  oh  what the world needs  now  what the world needs  you